[Music]
hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to talk about ikyo and not just
what ekyo is we kind of did a video on
talking about eq is but talk about why
ikyo is pivotal to aikido and why it is
the first of the techniques right so the
principal lessons why is it the first
principle lesson i think the reasons are
many most of the reasons though i've
heard i never bought so you know i've
heard people talk about like oh because
it teaches you the principle for how all
throws work
and while there's maybe some truth to
that i don't really think that's why
ikkyo ezekiel
oh it teaches you to stack someone's
spine in a way that makes them move you
know i've heard a lot of things like
this and they all sound a little magical
and woo-woo to me and i never liked that
so i think there's a really direct and
simple reason as to why ekyo is the
first and
most important technique in the system
and i'm going to get josh over here and
i'm going to talk to you about why that
is josh
all right so let's talk about ikyo
whatiko is
and why it is important in the system so
i was kind of always a a proponent of
the idea for a long time that like ecos
whatever it's eco you know it's a good
thing to kind of practice but it doesn't
have much practical application i always
heard people say like oh it's the first
technique in the system because it's so
important and a lot of teachers really
put a lot of emphasis on ikyo training
so it's like oh yeah eco must be
important but i didn't understand why
it kind of took me a long time to get
why eco might be important so ikyo looks
roughly like this my teacher was a big
fan of saying that ikyo makes an arc to
the ground and its primary objective
would be to take someone down
the first thing i think is important to
understand is i don't believe ekyo's
primary objective is to take someone
down i don't think it's that important
it could be used as a takedown like a
lot of techniques can be used to take
down but its main objective is exactly
what it's doing now if josh extended his
hand to hit me he can't hit me with his
hand right so if i put a knife in that
hand or he had a knife he can't cut me
right he can't do anything to me and
from a good control point right now
understand that that also is true here
okay also is true here
also is true here
right so in all those positions by
controlling his elbow he can't use a
weapon on me and i think that is
ikyo's first and important thing to do
it's a suppressing technique
which means you know if joshua's coming
at me with a knife one of the first
things i want to do is get elbow control
because anywhere else is bad so if i got
body control right he's just going to
load me up with stabs right if i try to
control his wrist it moves so fast that
it's likely he's going to get out of
that and he's going to going to get me
if i control his elbow or his shoulder
does nothing right so i really want to
try and get elbow control of some sort
so ikkyo's main idea is the way i teach
it is it is an elbow control that's the
number one most important part okay now
understand that it's gonna come up all
the time so that elbow control is gonna
come up all the time so let's say josh
presses in to get me so i'm not fast
enough to get away the second i move
here i just got elbow control so that's
what we do and we do that for all of our
techniques right when josh comes in
elbow control elbow control right all
the times we're moving around geowaza
you're constantly getting eco now it's
not the most dominant form of ikyo and
it's not an eco that takes someone down
it's not eco that hurts him or anything
but it does a really functional job for
me which is it keeps him from being able
to get me with that hand which is what i
want so if i control the elbow he can't
grab me if i control the elbow he can't
use a weapon on me so that's really good
all right now shomonucci echo
particularly is going to come up a ton
so understand
if i'm scared of this guy and he's going
to get me and i'm just trying to get out
of here i'm going to be cutting and
running and cutting and running right
when i cut and run his natural defense
is going to be this which is our
shomonucci position now what i would
like to do is go into something here
right to keep him from grabbing me so i
could control him right and i could
definitely use the weapon in lots of
ways here also if he were to get a hold
of my hand
hitting at that elbow in any kind of
fashion is likely to get his hand off of
me right so that's going to be another
great function of eq and why eq is so
important all right now if this guy has
a knife i also might need to use that as
a control but in truth really rokio is
going to work out better for me or nico
or coatigatch all kinds of other stuff
is going to work out better than this
eco so it's functional we could use it
that way but that's not going to be its
primary objective our primary objective
is just to hold the elbow now it does
come in great hand when i need to get
here and make my escape and you can see
i'm holding the eco and if josh will
stop for a second i can make my escape
so i i can get out of there by
controlling that elbow right and of
course if we did chase each other around
like that i could use it as a takedown
or i could transition into sanctuary i
could do something else now that's
another good point of why eco is so
important is it readily transitions into
all our other techniques right so let's
mock up go to this side for me let's
mock up that situation we just had okay
so i'm here and i'm trying to make my
escape this guy's sticking with me right
and wherever i move he'll stick with me
right this
my eco training allows me to quickly
slide into sankyo right allows me to
quickly transition into nikkyo right
allows me to quickly transition into
gokyo allows me to quickly transition
into a lot of the stuff we do so eco
also works as a transitioning technique
really really well so if he's armed and
i'm in a position the first thing i have
to do is suppress that elbow and then
after i suppress that elbow i'm going to
do something all our other techniques
transition really well from there so eco
is super important to the system of
aikido whether i have a weapon and i'm
trying to get away or whether he has a
weapon he's trying to get me it's going
to come up all the time but it's not for
some crazy
the spine aligns or it is the archetype
of all throws or whatever crazy thing
real simple if i hold someone at the
elbow they can't stab me with their
weapon and they can't grab me with their
hand which is what i want people not to
be able to do if they're coming to
attack me so that's my very straight and
direct translation of why eco is so
important to the system it seems obvious
when you see it like this although
before i spent years going why is eco
important because it doesn't hurt this
guy it doesn't anything else but the
emphasis of our system is not to hurt
him it's just keep him from hurting me
and ikyo does that beautifully so it's a
great first technique
i'm christopher hines this is joshua
tihi behind that camera which is really
far away we're using a different
wednesday it's maya solano mcdaniel
thanks for watching
[Music]
be
you